one of the biggest geopolitical blunders
of this administration has been Donald
Trump bailing on the Iran nuclear deal
importantly without Iran having violated
the deal which was of course signed
under President Barack Obama and you
might remember as many people did Trump
opposed the deal under Obama
lots of right-wingers did that and
that's fine but once the deal signed
willy-nilly canceling it when you're
elected president absent any cause to do
so based on what's in the deal is not a
good idea and I've said this before if
other countries can't trust that the
United States is going to stick to the
deals that we make even when a president
changes when the party in the
controlling the White House changes
there is no incentive to deal with us
there is no incentive to treat us
correctly it's geopolitically a disaster
and that's exactly what it has been I
also told you several weeks ago that
Iran completely predictably is now
resuming nuclear research and
development possibly for nuclear energy
possibly for nuclear weapons which of
course I don't want them to have but the
point is they're resuming enrichment of
uranium which I don't want them to do
but given the circumstances it's
perfectly logical it's perfectly
rational and it's what we would expect
that they would do Iran knows that if
they are not if the United States has
bailed on the Iran nuclear deal they are
better off no matter what happens in the
future starting to enrich uranium again
either they start enriching uranium so
that in the future it becomes a
negotiating point for a future deal or
they start enriching uranium either to
develop nuclear power or nuclear weapons
because if they understand history they
know that historically having nuclear
weapons has been a strong positioning
item positioning it has been strong for
the positioning of nations and there are
numerous examples that we can look at
and those include we've talked about
Iraq we've talked about many others so
it's completely predictable that it's
what Iran would do I don't want them to
do it but I get why they're doing it and
what Donald Trump is now doing is trying
to have it both ways
Trump has bailed on the deal
he has pulled the United States out of
the Iran nuclear deal but at the same
time is demanding that Iran stick to the
deal unless they want to face further
consequences for not sticking to the
deal and here's the loophole that the
Trump administration is trying to use to
justify this nonsense what the u.s. is
saying is that even though we pulled out
of the deal there are other countries
that are still in the deal and this is
of course the height of absurdity the
Donald Trump backed the United States
out of the Iran nuclear deal it was a
coalition deal so the argument they're
making is the u.s. is out but Iran is
still in the deal with the UK and with
France and with Germany and of course on
a technical level that may be but then
it's up to those countries to demand
that Iran comply Donald Trump and the
United States have no credibility
whatsoever to even ask for that at this
point in time and even worse is that the
United States has actually made it
almost impossible for the other
countries to keep working with Iran on
compliance so Donald Trump has sort of
put himself into a very strange and
idiotic corner but specifically a corner
that lacks all credibility on the issue
and unfortunately and this really is a
problem there are news outlets that are
reporting that Iran would be in
violation of the deal if they do this or
if they did that Trump ripped up the
agreement it makes it hard for other
countries to keep it going but when
Donald Trump does that and then yet he
still insists that Iran has to stick
with the deal and more importantly maybe
we're used to Trump's hypocrisy and
idiocy and ignorance domestically but
geopolitically this starts to put Europe
once again potentially at odds with the
United States because ultimately those
other countries the European signatories
to the Iran deal might have to say we
agree with the u.s. even though Trump
backed out the deal with us is still on
and Iran needs to abide by it that would
be taking Trump's side when it comes to
this disagreement or the European
signatories might say even though this
is a multi-part
by ripping it up as far as American
involvement the deal is effectively dead
and we really have no sort of compliance
authority to enforce that Iran stick to
it and this is yet another one of these
examples of how the United States will
be pitted against Europe and we've
talked about this before when the US and
Europe are at odds this is a win for
Putin who wants to put a wedge between
the United States and our allies a lot
of Putin's prerogatives and priorities
when it comes to NATO relate to driving
a wedge between the United States and
Europe this relates to so much of what
we've been talking about over the last
couple of years and it's not this
cartoonish Trump and Putin colluding
thing it's that Donald Trump doesn't
even have the wherewithal and the
knowledge and the intelligence quite
frankly
to even understand the ways in which his
actions and statements regarding Europe
and other allies and his looking away
when it's convenient to look away from
authoritarian leaders doing absolutely
terrible things
it all fits into a politic that benefits
Vladimir Putin in a world in which
Russia and China are increasingly
aligned to the detriment of the United
States as sort of the third leg of the
nuclear of the superpowers the three
growing geopolitical superpowers and
we've talked about this many many times
before it doesn't have to be Trump
colluding with Putin to be executing a
politic that benefits Putin in ways that
Russia has been thinking about and
talking about at least for two plus
decades if not longer this in the end is
going to be what it's about we'd be
better off if Donald Trump had not
backed out of the deal Iran would be
further back in their nuclear
development everyone would be safer with
an Iran that is still part of the deal
and complying with the Iran nuclear deal
instead we have an Iran that is newly
invigorated in its nuclear development
there are new discussions of war with
Iran on the table and it's absolutely
absurd and utterly embarrassing on the
Nationals
which has basically been the theme of
this administration if you disagree let
me know I want to hear from you about
the Iran nuclear deal about Iran's
actions in resuming enrichment of
uranium about the context in which Putin
likes the idea of the United States at
odds with Europe about what does or
doesn't Iran have to do with regard to
what is remaining the tatters of the
Iran nuclear deal let me know what you
think